at the high court to see what is going
on we've got our Chopper up there as
well we've got it covered from every
single angle he's not getting in without
us seeing him is he going to get chilled
off for not turning up yesterday Adam I
I think the judge will will leave it I
think you may get a short apology from
the prince potentially but I think
they'll crack on get straight into it
they've already lost a bit of time it's
a bit Daft of him not to come yesterday
wasn't it it was a bit dark I think from
his point of view psychologically he
wants to go in there feeling like he's
put his best foot forward and feeling
comfortable and relaxed keeping an eye
on this car this might be them I think
it looks as though it's a royal car
doesn't got all the lights on and
everything yeah that says Royal all over
it doesn't it doesn't it yeah so this is
Prince Harry
um we think arriving at the high court
certainly the Snappers behind seem to
think it is there he is
[Applause]